énormément de courage d'y aller
la prod il aurait dû te mettre un
dentiste
urgent
j'ai un centre dentaire moi à mon avis
frère tu me demandes j'ai tout méchants
alors les chéris hier c'était la
cinquième le cinquième épisode de la 18e
saison de l'amour et dans le pré si vous
avez loupé l'épisode on vous a fait un
petit débrief alors hier il y avait 6
agriculteurs on recherche d'amour on
s'est focalisé sur les quatre qui ont le
plus fait parler sur les réseaux et on
commence avec Roméo producteur de
fourrage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais aimé faire une formation déjà
de j'aurais voulu faire parce que je
masse au siège je fais des massages
[Musique]
on va pouvoir se déshabiller un petit
peu et puis non
on va aller faire un tour avec les
tracteurs donc je vous prendrai une une
après l'autre non
[Applaudissements]
ensuite on s'est intéressé à Julien
essaie de prétendantes c'est de
prétendre d'ailleurs Bastien et Thibault
Julien pour ceux qui ont loupé la
semaine dernière c'est le maniaque de la
chaussure regardez
bon par contre et tu peux m'enlever les
godasses oui bien sûr
comment vas-tu
alors vous allez voir que Thibault il a
pas passé une super nuit et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi tout de suite
très content d'être là ça il y a pas de
souci mais pas super bien dormi vu que
j'ai un voisin de chambre qui s'appelle
je crois Bastien qui a rempli toute la
nuit qui a parlé c'était top
donc j'ai hésité entre
[Musique]
les tuer ou
retourner de me rendormir
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que est-ce que Julien tu sais
c'est ton style ou pas du tout alors
c'est mon style mais il a un caractère
qui est bien trempé quand même quelque
chose que ça n'aurait pas fait ça
l'aurait pas fait tu as pas eu de coeur
physiquement ça va mais vraiment le
caractère c'est c'est pas pour moi
alors comment Bastien a vécu sa nuit et
ben regardez lui plutôt bien regardez le
ronfleur donc finalement tu as dormi
avec le chauffage non non ça a été plus
parce que moi enfin j'ai trouvé que dans
la pièce il faisait bon je me suis levé
les c'est quoi
deux heures
deux heures et demie quand tu as
commencé à ronfler par les quoi
alors
on va passer à Olivier l'éleveur de
moutons de la Creuse il risque pas d'y
avoir de tension entre ses prétendantes
parce que lui c'est un peu Jack la
poisse une de ses prétendantes c'est
déjà barré regardez
ah oui j'ai Laurine ne viendra pas
pourquoi parce que la des problèmes
enfin elle a repris un boulot et puis
elle a des problèmes avec
disons familiale on ne viendra voilà
je pensais que voilà
si
c'est dommage comme ça
alors et c'est aussi Olivier c'est aussi
Jack la galère il a des galères qui
partagent avec sa seule prétendante du
coup pas sûr que ça l'aide à pécho
regardez moi j'ai un ami il a une
piscine et les vaches elles ont
remontées de nuit et elle est arrivée
elle est tombée dans la piscine oh là là
mais le problème c'est qu'elle
commençait à se noyer parce que l'eau
rentrée par l'anus de la vache c'est
intéressant je dois peut-être reprendre
porter des semelles orthopédiques je
marche tout de travers
au début je pensais que j'ai des
problèmes de enfin j'ai eu des problèmes
dans ça je me suis fait opérer des
poissons une année j'ai une génisse de 2
ans qui est passé sous le train
[Musique]
il tournait le nerf dans la testicule et
après c'était le véto il coupe il ouvre
les bourses et puis ils sont les
testicules en dormant localement nous
sommes un peu une véritable boucherie
sympa la soirée
alors enfin il y avait Anaïs l'éleveuse
de chèvre de 35 ans qui avait déjà reçu
son premier prétendant de Thomas et
attendez avec impatience celui qui avait
été son coup de cœur Romain qui n'est
pas venu les mains vides Anaïs était
comme une folle mais pas ouf non
je suis quand même franchement posé la
question
si c'était une bonne idée il fait peur à
toi
à toi de la prouver ou pas
[Musique]
de circulation c'était dans la voiture
il y a pas de souci après c'est vrai que
ça me donne un peu de boulot en plus
parce que du coup elles savent pas
encore vivre au nez je peux pas les
mettre tout de suite avec les autres
pour une histoire sanitaire je préfère
les garder un peu en quarantaine et puis
surtout j'ai déjà gardé beaucoup trop de
chevrettes quoi alors
romain à part faire des cadeaux un peu
relou il a des tendances chelou il est
pas hyper rassurant le gars t'as pas
envie de le croiser dans le noir
regardez
un couteau
ok
ça commence à m'inquiéter cette histoire
on passera un petit coup de détecteur
sur toi vérifier qu'il y ait pas au nord
une prothèse quelque part qui pourrait
être identifiée
plutôt une pelle pour enterrer ton
enfant du jardin je vais pas dire que ça
me fait peur non plus mais je trouve ça
je trouve ça bizarre en fait alors vous
allez voir en plus que Romain plus
s'explique puisse regarder
pourquoi tu as une perle dans ta voiture
en fait à part on pour enterrer Thomas
c'était coliné
toujours ça dans ma caisse quand toi je
me casse en vadrouille en weekend ou
quoi ou que j'aille chez mes parents
c'est le matos que je prends tout le
temps donc tu as envie de sonder
[Musique]
la saison de L'amour est dans le pré
cette année oui je pense que ça manque
un petit peu de piment c'est ça on est
d'accord
oh tu nous dis si tu trouves l'amour
bien sûr avec lui
attendez merci merci tu es toujours
bienvenue si moi j'en